it's it's like i have to wonder if these
journalists have the memory of a
goldfish or if it's on purpose
well it's this whole thing with with uh
john roberts the other day
when john john roberts is like look
um can you say now now he's talking
he's talking to the press secretary and
the press secretary is basically
she she does not she's not
she can't make a decision for trump she
doesn't dictate for the president
she can't say like it's like does does
trump
uh does he condemn it and then she
like she goes yes he definitively does
instead what she said was
here's multiple examples of the
president
condemning like the people you want to
condemn
here and then and she's like oh back in
this state back in this state he said
this he said this
and then he goes uh but
can you say right now that he condemns
it
it's like well i just read you like he's
he's how many times
you could have him condemn it like every
hour on the hour
and it would never be good enough for
these people i know right so
what people need to understand about
kaylee mcinerney she doesn't
speak for trump so when a journalist
says does donald trump right now condemn
it exactly she goes
let me read you a quote from the
president no i want you i want to know
now
she can't be like yes i hereby on behalf
of the president
announce a quote for him from my mouth
and instead she's
she's saying this is when he said these
things
these are the dates multiple times
how many more times does he need to say
every hour does he yeah does he need to
like
does he need to do like a video and this
is going to help him this
i think this absolutely is going to help
him win you know why but people still
believe it yes yes like but people now
think that he's still a racist
and he's still like even the proud boys
the proud boys are not
white supremacists i know they they're
not white supremacists so
so it's like fine you want to condemn
them whatever
right there are a lot of things a lot of
things to be criticized for sure yeah
perhaps
absolutely you know i don't think that
violence
look they're they they seem they seem
like
a lot of them seem like decent guys
right
that's fine but i don't think that that
going down to a place to say okay well
there's going to be these
these uh you know there's going to be
these uh
protesters so let's go down and see if
some trouble happens well
no but but so so what they do is we're
going to go to portland and have a free
speech rally
right or march and it's like you do know
what's going to happen if you go to
portland right well we're allowed to do
it that's true you
are but you do know what's going to
happen if you go do that right
well to be fair i was very critical of
them over the portland thing and then
nothing happened
right but it's almost exclusively that
antifa starts fights with them
that's almost always how it happens but
the
the argument i guess is if you go to a
place where you know
a bunch of crazy people are going to
start fighting you like at a certain
point like
what you got to understand about car
accidents is that failure to avoid an
accident is actually your fault
so i don't you're familiar with that
right yeah yeah a lot of people
don't realize this they think if if
someone rear-ends me then it's their
fault no matter what actually that's not
true
if there's a witness like that car was
like down the street and this guy
sat there and didn't move when this guy
was coming forward right like parked
like failure to avoid an accident can be
your fault but it
i guess the the big challenge the proud
boys is just like
where do you draw the line and saying i
won't go and have my rally because
the hecklers veto so there's a challenge
there look
i don't want to go off on a big thing on
on the proud boys because we're talking
about you know trump and the journalists
and we got to finish the john roberts
thing
they're not white supremacists we can
have a conversation about
the morality of going to places like
portland where you know that luck lacked
a fool and the right for you to do it
peacefully without without having people
attack you for sure
but the john roberts thing was was funny
because he's trying to get kaylee
mcinenny
to issue a trump quote live in real time
with trump not present
which she can't do right and then when
she said let me read you the quotes in
the president
and he's like yeah but what about now
and she goes i can't do anything but
read these things to you
and then he get he gets attacked on
twitter and it got all triggered about
it
went on tv and he was like i don't care
i just don't
it had to be asked no it didn't it was
asked over and over again i'm so sick of
it but listen
the main point is it's going to help
trump you know why i understand
you're saying there are people who
believe trump's a racist and he won't
announce this stuff yeah but those
people weren't going to vote for trump
anyway
and i'd imagine a good portion of them
know that
the whole argument is bs and are just
like oh here's my chance to lie to
convince more people that trump's bad
but regular people staying at home are
probably like what's it talking about
what's a proud boy
is that an lgbt i don't know what
they're talking about well now
now they they they hear proud boy
you know trump won't announce the proud
voice so that must mean that they're bad
right right right now and not ever and
not everybody
saw that segment on cnn where where um
enrique tario
yeah no no it was uh one of the
commentators was like
they're they're kind of like a uh a
fight club you know kind of trolls yeah
like
they're not they're like they say
they're not white supremacists
and she she wasn't trying to say like
well they say they're not
blah you know uh or or they're they're
they're a hate group you know like well
trump isn't trump told them to stand by
so of course
of course you know that they're bad i
think trump spoke
i think he was uh yeah i think so i
think he was flustered and he wouldn't
shut up
okay so so i know i said that and people
are like dude joe biden was lying and
i'm like i know
joe biden was lying and then trump was
like wrong no
and like jumping in two things can be
this true at the same time trump
needs to let joe biden speak you know
why
because he can't the more joe biden
speaks the more he goes
and with trump cutting him off joe is
probably like thank you
how many gaffes does joe biden put out
per minute the more trump speaks
the less gaffes from joe biden there
were several instances in that debate
where biden was like
20 20 million 20 20 19 yeah
let him go for it trump trump can yes
joe speak more please i want i want the
white house to come out and say
look um it turns out
that uh the president was feeling under
the weather
and uh he just wasn't his
old self like he was just a little more
uh
you know he just wanted to get in there
and he was he was just a little bit more
triggered than normal and um and that's
it
and just say normally he's not like this
because he's had good debates
yeah but then but you have to also
remember that in the first debate
with hillary he did not do great he was
off his game
mm-hmm uh he was off his game this time
too for sure he definitely was off his
camera yeah
i missed so many things like come on
just like trump needs to calm down
uh and and it's true and and if there
happens to
be a second or third debate and who
knows at this point yeah who knows if
there's even going to be a vice
presidential debate
uh lydia earlier was saying that um
maybe for like a national security
reason you know that you might not want
to put
uh mike pence in a situation where he
could be exposed that's a good point so
and it was a great point and it makes a
lot of sense and
i really do want to see a vice
presidential debate because i would like
to see like
a debate yeah yeah and mike pence is
he's really good on the debate stage i
think he's going to demolish commonly i
think so too and and i know like it's
it's cliche of tim poole to wreck on the
democrats but
think about kamala as she is
so fake she's just such a fake person
wearing tims tupac's the greatest rapper
alive
lady it's been 30 years what are you
talking about
did she like google like she went to
like a geocities website
and like what is the best rapper
somehow she ends up on a website with
like a gif of macho man randy savage
doing like the peanut butter jelly dance
and there's like really crappy comic
sans writing and it's like tupac's the
best
and she's like that's good enough for me
remember when she like claimed to listen
to rap that didn't come out when she was
in college like
she is plastic now mike pence is a lot
of things
but he's a politician you know he's he's
he's
a well i don't the right word is but
a suit a square i don't mean that a bad
way i mean like he's a stodgy normal
professional kind of
downtown kind of guy i mean i think a
lot of people know that already because
if you remember the cr if you remember
the first coronavirus briefings
you'd have trump going on there he's
like blah blah blah blah and then mike
pence comes on he's like
yeah all right he was so calm and you're
just like
mike pence is looking very presidential
right now yeah
very presidential and you know like i'm
i'm feeling i'm feeling calm now
yeah exactly it's true though you know
because and you know
you have this dr burks and they seem to
get along
and i actually real real quick at the
chronovirus uh briefings at the
beginning
uh i remember he was he was saying uh he
was calling
dr fauci but then he he would call dr
berksy say deborah
and people were like no it's doctor you
know
it's like it's you know just because
she's a woman
and you're like uh no because they're
like he calls
tony he says he refers to tony you know
you're just not like watching the whole
thing you're just like watching
they're just finding something to
pretend to be mad about worse all it is
of course it is that's why i remember
that it was crazy it's it's
this is why i think this kind of stuff
helps trump the uh
you know the john roberts thing the jim
acosta thing is because i tell you man
there's probably a bunch of regular
people who are like there's no way
you're actually mad
there's no way you're actually mad i was
mad i don't know why
no i'm not mad i mean i mean about like
he called oh the guy saying he called oh
john roberts was mad no
i'm talking about the people who are
like he called dr burke's
debra oh i'm i'm on this there's going
to be some like suburban house wife
sitting there with with
uh with her husband he's going to get
back from work and she's going to be
like
who cares what does that have to do with
anything
my husband's losing his job because of
the pandemic and we didn't know what
we're gonna do with our kids
well i i will definitely say that that
when it comes to those dumb little
things
especially especially this uh trump
didn't
like he's condemned it a billion times
but he didn't he hasn't done it yet or
he won't do it now and you're like
like do you think he changed his mind
yeah that's yeah right
there was like a period where like trump
woke up in the middle of the night
nicole
i was wrong to denounce these groups 57
times oh my goodness what
what was i thinking uh you know they're
good people on both sides but
but i i think a lot of uh i just did a
man in the street
uh interview i went out to california of
all places
and there were people like when you
talked to the biden people they're like
well i'm voting for biden because i want
to get rid of trump
but all of the the trump people were
like
uh he's being treated unfairly he's
condemned it multiple times uh like they
they know what they like about trump
right they're like he's done this he's
done this he's done this
uh so i think that i think that the
majority
of trump supporters know that this whole
that whole condemning not condemning
it's just bs
right and the more the media pushes it
the more that his base will get riled up
about it right and it's almost like uh
you're helping you're helping him get
elected that's that's this
look this is the point if the democrats
in the media just like
took a second to breathe and they said
how about we nominate someone who's just
calm a populist moderate kind of like
trump
but not as bombastic and and you know
kind of
ill-tempered they would win
and people would be like look donald
trump's talking about that border
security but so is you know john jackson
john jackson doesn't have a potty mouth
you know what i mean look i understand a
lot of trump supporters say who cares if
trump
talks this way and i know a lot of them
say they like that he talks to suede to
a point
yeah but i've like i've been uh in ubers
i've been to restaurants and i hear it
all the time from people who say they're
voting for trump that they wish he
wouldn't talk this way
we all say that yeah no there are some
people who are laughing and they love it
it's hilarious and they like it
but i don't think that they're into
politics as much you know like no no
those are like the
die hards you know right there's super
there's people that like i i would not
call myself
like a like super i love trump i
i really i respect him i respect the
fact that he's
he's doing all the things he said he was
going to
do um which is one of the reasons why
the left is so freaked out
well these pieces are actually getting
things oh my god that peace agreement is
so awesome
three peace agreements three mind you
sir and
and you can bit like we're i mean i'm
all over the place here but
i like i that kind of thing oh but you
know he's
he's a he's a white supremacist he's a
racist you're like
you're like no no like you think he
would care
you know do you think he's just doing it
for the nobel prize because he's not
going to win it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you